joining us now is the author of the
complete infidels guide to free speech
and its enemies Robert Spencer is with
us how do you explain that Robert I I
think I'm accurate in saying there
hasn't been a major attack in some time
in Europe and America no you're quite
right and the fact is however that as
Isis is collapsing in Iraq and Syria
they have issued explicit calls to uh
come back to Europe come to the United
States and kill innocent civilians here
so I don't think that we can conclude
from this relative period of quiet that
it's all over no but could you conclude
that we're taking the right steps to get
in front of the terrorist before they
act to some degree yes there's an
undeniably uh so that there are many
many attacks that have been thwarted
there are many more Jihad plots than
there are Jihad massacres at the same
time however there are incredibly
wrong-headed policies being pursued the
UK for example is not alone in saying
that Isis Fighters if they are citizens
of Great Britain then they have to let
them back into the country and there are
at least 40 confirmed Isis jihadis who
are walking around in Britain today the
British know authorities know that
they're there but they are not under
surveillance they are not in custody
they could be plotting something
catastrophic right now and they probably
are okay I want to ask you one more
question about State Department lawyers
America's State Department lawyers
removing the word genocide from reports
of Christian Slaughter that sounds like
political bias one way or the other
you're shaking your head What's
Happening Here well there's no doubt
that these are Obama administration
holdovers it was Obama administration
policy not to call the muslim
persecution of Christians in the Middle
East genocide they shied away from doing
anything that was offensive to Islam or
Muslims and Trump he needs to drain this
swamp but it has not happened um but I
am right in saying that they did stop
the use of the word genocide when you're
talking about Christian
Slaughter yes absolutely this was this
was something that was explicitly done
and was done by an Obama appointee who
remains in Authority in the state
department he remains in Authority in
the state department and that's very
interesting that's quite so so we
haven't changed that yet because we
haven't changed the
Personnel the state department there's a
civil war going on right now in the
state department between people who want
to follow the policies that the
president has delineated in many
addresses and those who want to continue
the Obama Administration policies of
denial and willful ignorance regarding
the Jihad threat okay Robert look thanks
very much for joining us this morning
I'm sorry to cut it short I wanted to
give the reasonable news that we
happened had a big incident recently and
You' backed that you you've countered
that with we're not doing exactly the
right thing on the home front Robert
thanks for joining us we appreciate you
being with us thank you thank you all
right here's a warning watch out High
income earners president Trump telling
the Wall Street Journal higher taxes on
the wealthy could be coming there's a
surprise we're on it after
this what a day on Wall Street stocks
came under pressure of new highs from
the NASDAQ energy technology finished in
the green up arrows for the day I'm
Nicole pedales Fox Business today we're
out here with some big news about type 2
diabetes you have type two diabetes
right yes so let me ask you this how
does diabetes affect your heart it
doesn't doesn't actually it it does type
two diabetes can make you twice as
likely to die from a cardiovascular
event like a heart attack or stroke and
with heart disease your risk is even
higher you didn't know that no yeah but
wait there's good news for adults who
have type two diabetes and heart disease
jardians is the only type two diabetes
pill with a life-saving cardiovascular
benefit jardians has proven to both
significantly reduce the chance of dying
from a cardiovascular event in adults
who have type 2 diabetes and heart
disease and lower your A1C jardians can
cause serious side effects including
dehydration this may cause you to feel
dizzy faint or lightheaded or weak upon
standing keto acidosis is a serious side
effect that may be fatal symptoms
include nausea vomiting stomach pain
tiredness and trouble breathing stop
taking jardians and call your doctor
right away if you have symptoms of Keto
acidosis or an allergic reaction
symptoms of an allergic reaction include
rash swelling and difficulty breathing
or swallowing do not take jardians if
you're on dialysis or have severe kidney
problems other side effects are sudden
kidney problems genital yeast infections
increased bad cholesterol and urinary
tract infections which may be serious
taking jardians with a sanura or insulin
may cause low blood sugar tell your
doctor about all the medic